after all the controversy surrounding
the lack of rtx on and the inflated
pricing of the rtx 2080 today is the day
that many of you have been waiting for
the launch of the less expensive and
more obtainable
rtx
but just because something is affordable
doesn't mean you should buy it
intrigued
good that's the point of this entire
paragraph it's called a hook
and this part is called a sponsor glass
wire allows you to instantly see your
current and past network activity detect
malware and block badly behaving apps on
your pc or android device use offer code
linus and get 25 off at the link below
[Music]
the biggest headline feature of the 2070
somewhat ironically is the one that it
doesn't have so for the first time since
nvidia changed to their current naming
scheme back in 2008 the
70 value enthusiast card doesn't do
sli
all that remains of the 1070s sli
functionality is this sad little cutout
in the shroud that no longer serves any
purpose whatsoever
not that we've really pushed sli as a
sensible solution for years so
i guess nvidia's slow march towards
killing what used to be one of their
highlight enthusiast features only
really bothers me on a nostalgic level
let's change gears now then to something
that bothers me a little bit more
objectively
pricing with the enthusiast rtx cards
this honestly didn't bother me as much
because the 80 series has traditionally
targeted the affluent gamer who cares
less about price to performance and more
about raw power
but the reference rtx 2070 is priced at
500 us dollars with the overclocked
founders edition priced at 600 us
dollars
that puts these new
2070 cards not directly up against the
previous 1070
but rather the gtx 1080 from nvidia's
last generation lineup and amd's vega 56
so we'll be comparing all of these cards
today although sadly we'll only be using
our intel bench since time was not on
our side like no joke we actually got
our card 18 hours before this video was
supposed to go live
it's a good thing anthony's a good sport
about this kind of thing
so with deus ex mankind divided we get a
pretty big jump in performance over the
gtx 1080.
and that's pretty much the end of that
chapter with the rest of our test suite
getting just a few frames per second
more regardless of whether we're looking
at directx 11 or directx 12. 3dmark and
unigine's superposition do let the 2070
stretch its legs a little bit more but
overall we are in the same ballpark as
our reference gtx 1080 and a factory
overclocked 1080 would probably be on
par when we hit it with our productivity
workloads though like its bigger cousins
the rtx 2070 delivers consistently good
performance compared to the gtx 1080 of
yesteryear making it quite comparable in
most cases to even the rx vega 64. even
in opencl tasks like luxmark that
typically favor vega and in heavy
lifting tasks like most but not all of
specvuperf's professional rendering
workloads it should of course be noted
that most enthusiasts and professionals
won't want to go for a reference card
like this one preferring instead to opt
for something like this strix but the
thing is while normally these beefier
custom cards quickly fall close to
reference pricing
this time it might take a while the 499
msrp that nvidia has slapped onto
reference cards allegedly has their
partner selling these boards for
basically no margin
and why should you the consumer care
about that
well because as a result you can expect
to pay closer to the founders edition
599 price point for custom board cards
for the foreseeable future
and with this being the lowest tier of
gpu with tensor cores and rtx support
that means that 500 to 600
will be the lowest point of entry for
these technologies until nvidia delivers
a 3 000 series refresh sometime in oh i
don't know let's say 2022 at the rate
that they're going
so then rtx 2070 to buy or not to buy
it's a really complicated question so
let's start with the price
on the surface it's not that much higher
than the 1080 that it traded blows with
in our benchmarks
but
msrp aside aggressive sale prices have
1080s as low as 65 cheaper already and
that's right now while we're working on
this video before the 2070 has even
launched so i would expect them to go
lower still
which means that what we need to
determine then is if the features of the
new gen justify the added expense
some of them are pretty easy to evaluate
like the improved nvenk encoder that
outputs similar quality real-time
capture to x264 fast with a negligible
performance hit that's going to be a
huge hit for anyone who game streams go
for it
other features well gets more
complicated because
surprise there is still
no real rtx games there's no real
content to set this thing apart from the
last gen or even to measure how much of
a performance impact that we might
expect from the real-time ray tracing
feature that nvidia is banking on so
hard to sell these things that they put
it right in the name
further complicating the matter is the
used market right now so with the recent
cryptocurrency mining crash sites like
ebay have been absolutely flooded with
last generation high performance gpus
and right now 1080 ti's which perform
more like an rtx 2080 in conventional
games can be had for the same price as
an rtx 2070 and as we demonstrated in
this video a used video card might not
carry any warranty but it'll perform
exactly the same after it's heavy use as
it did when it was new we can't tell you
not to buy an rtx 2070 because it's it's
fine i guess but we can't tell you to
buy it because its main selling points
are still completely missing in action
the only thing that we really can say
conclusively today is that this launch
from nvidia is all the evidence that we
need to say that they absolutely require
a competitor to keep their pricing in
line
rather than follow the it industry
standard of
mostly inflationary pricing increases
that even intel
intel maintained through the second to
sixth generation core series processor
launches
remember this is when they had no
competition from amd to speak of nvidia
has just kicked the convention to the
curb
instead of using the architectural
improvements to deliver more bang for
the buck to consumers nvidia has instead
taken their new products and basically
plonked them right down on top of the
old ones so instead of taking the money
that you had last year and getting more
for it today
you can get more but you will just need
to shell out extra cash
i mean the argument from nvidia might be
that rtx is what adds more bang for
those bucks
but at this point i'm just being asked
to take their word for it and i can't do
that
you know what i can do is tell you guys
about ting ting is the mobile carrier
that's focused on customer service and
satisfaction with ting when you call
them this is crazy you don't speak to a
robot you get put through directly to a
person who can help you and you don't
pay extra for the privilege with ting
you pay only for what you use with the
average bill coming in at just 23 bucks
a month per device if you're stuck in a
contract and switch to ting they'll even
cover 25 of your cancellation fee and
they have lower mobile data rates than
ever before it's just ten dollars per
gig beyond the second gig so go check
out their savings calculator at
linus2018.ting.com
and find out how much you'd be able to
save on ting we're gonna have that link
down below and if you use our link
you're going to get 25 bucks off your
bill or towards a new phone
so thanks for watching guys if you
disliked this video then i'm sorry i'm
sorry nvidia staff out there i mean we
tried to be nice to it but like what are
we supposed to say it's like faster
video cards for more expensive it's not
like a huge win for the average gamer
maybe maybe
non-rtx what is it going to be a gtx
2060 this is going to get really
confusing so if you guys dislike this
video you can hit that button but if you
liked it hit like get subscribed or
maybe consider checking out where to buy
the stuff we featured at the link below
also down there is our merch store which
has cool shirts like this one no whoops
no not like this one we have cool shirts
there though and our community forum
which you should totally join